[Music]
hello everybody i'm josh welsh president
of film independent and welcome to film
independent presents
uh we are very excited today to be uh
having a we've screened the film and now
we're having a conversation with the
director
of i am greta nathan grossman nathan
thank you so much for being here
uh it's it's wonderful to have you thank
you josh
um before we start i just a couple of
quick thank yous uh from film
independent i want to thank
our lead funder the hollywood foreign
press association
the hipaa makes our year-round screening
program possible so thank you to the
hfpa
also thanks to our screening partner
vision media that's the platform that we
use for screening all the films
uh and then last but certainly not least
thank you to the los angeles times our
media partner for this program
um we love all of you and are deeply
grateful
that we're able to continue doing
programming thanks to all of your
generosity
um nathan i i just i love this film so
much
that i'm i'm really excited to talk to
you and learn i i don't know much of the
back
story of how the film got to be made so
um
but you know greta tunberg is such an
incredible character for a film and i
felt like i learned so much about her
and her family
and her trajectory over the course of
this and honestly just the access that
you had being able to spend time with
her over an extended period of time
was really remarkable so i hope if
people are watching this who haven't
seen the film yet
please go check it out in the u.s it's
available on hulu
but available worldwide i believe at
this point um
nathan could you going back to the
beginning so the first
the film starts with her she's just
alone sitting outside the parliament
um how did this how did you come to this
story how did it start was that the
beginning where you just
were following a kind of unknown girl or
what how did it come about
yeah like many documentaries it started
with a tip
i got a tip from a friend of mine that
knew greta's family a little bit
that she was going to do some kind of a
small manifestation outside the
swedish parliament and this was in the
summer of 2018 and we'd had a very warm
summer in sweden with lots of forest
fires
and i've been doing some kind of
documentaries that
is not directly on climate change but
kind of in relationship to it
and so i had a discussion with my boss
and i was like
maybe it's interesting to at least do
some kind of a request to see
what kind of person this is and what
kind of an activism this is because you
know
i remember i googled greta thonberg in
sweden then and there were like just a
few results
she'd had done uh like uh like an op-ed
thing with one newspaper and i read that
and was like this is interesting
but it was still one of those you know
kind of long shots so i decided to go to
these
this tiny street which is outside the
swedish parliament building
and there she sat by the by this kind of
stone wall with her sign
and uh i had never seen her before and
in the beginning it was actually a bit
hard finding her even i remember me and
the sound engineer we kind of looked
around
like is she even doing this
and um then i i talked to her and said
you know i
i might just be here for for a day you
know to do a wreck so don't get
sad if i if i don't kind of stay that's
just the way
the filmmaking works you know but piece
by piece
people started to talk to her and other
journalists passed by and and you know
and and and i kind of felt that she has
something and decided to
kind of continue following and was she
open when you first
spoke to her like that was she open to
it did she talk to you about what she
was doing or you were mainly observing
her talking to other people
no of course i i told her about me and
what i was doing and and she was kind of
very kind of she of course did this
because she wanted people to kind of
recognize it uh and we're like as long
as you don't interfere with my activism
and of course i
you know i called i think it was the
father because i got his number from her
and called up and said you know
just to get consent uh because she was a
minor
um but but it was more and as you can
see in the film i don't want to spoil
too much
for the ones who haven't seen but it's
in the beginning i i don't have much
access and it's more
kind of me trying to to figure a way to
kind of
start capturing this and then piece by
piece when her activism kind of
continued and i
kind of went back and back again and got
more kind of trust
the film kind of starts to get closer in
a sense
how long was that process from that
first day when you filmed her
out on the street to when you realized
this was going to be a feature film
focused on her where there was like you
know it became the film that it is
no but it was actually a fairly long
process which i think many
documentarians kind of recognize
themselves that
you you you're following something and
you don't have any idea
in the beginning what it is even and
then you don't know where it's heading
so i i think it took me until
sometime in the winter of 2018 that i
followed for a few
months and more more and then i didn't
work full-time on it either
because i didn't really know if it was
that interesting
apart from a nordic perspective but then
suddenly strikes in australia and
belgium started to pop up and
there were not just you know 500 kids
like it was in the nordics
on these marches but it was tens of
thousands of kids
and many of them had signs saying you
know i stand with you greta
and then in that moment i think i i it
really struck me that
her way of kind of talking about this
issue that you know compressing it down
to something
something that was so emotional and easy
to understand
it made an impact on people far from
from sweden and
and i decided to to really kind of step
it up a notch and start following her
more and travel on and so on
it's remarkable so she's when you first
were filming her with how old was she
then 15
when she was out on the street yeah yeah
i i think it was 15 years
wow so that the i mean there's there's
so much that's remarkable in this film
that i mean all the footage of her
travels and
and her you know every scene of her
speaking is remarkable but
one of the things i wanted to talk about
was also her relationship with her
father
and the sort of including that in the
film there's this
beautiful access that you get to her and
her father seeing them together and
seeing that relationship just kind of
you know parent-child dynamic and but
also at the same time there's this
extraordinary thing happening where
she's
suddenly her voice is magnified and can
you talk about how you approach that
with her father and
was that pretty straightforward getting
that access or
how did you navigate sort of filming
these intimate
personal family scenes with the bigger
story
no but but i think it was some time
when i started to to to decide to kind
of go more dependent and i asked greta
if i could join on
on one of the first trips that she was
taking uh
and then the father he's he's what we
used in sweden called a
papa which is like at home father i
think i don't know if you have it in the
states but it's the equivalent of an at
home
mom but it's a dad um and he was you
know driving the car and
and helping her and i remember i sat in
the back seat of the car
and that was my first like interaction
with him where i kind of more spent time
with him just
seeing him pass before and i i had to
kind of bite my lip because i was almost
laughing because
this kind of teenage relationship was
was
instantly popping up just as you know
when you were young and you traveled
with a
family friend and you were you know you
know you know in the car with them and
suddenly you understand okay so this is
the dynamic and i was like i
instantly felt that this is something i
want to include in the film uh
this is such an important kind of part
of the story and it's also
like the movie i i wanted to to be from
her point of view
because i thought there was so many so
much noise of analysis and
ideas around her and and not kind of
no one really trying to get into inside
her head
um but but i felt that the father uh
in kind of more verite scenes
was such a funny and interesting and an
emotional
person to kind of bounce her feelings
towards so that became
an a large part of the plot that
relationship
and um as you were filming that i mean i
love how it
as you said it you're telling it from
her point of view so
the father is there and he clearly has
his view on things and he's like
talking to her about like editing the
speech or how she needs to eat food like
those scenes really pop out
but it's like what comes through in that
is
her strength of character or her
stubbornness or
her determination to do things her way
like she hears him she responds but
there's just this
the focus remains on her like she's the
one making the decisions in that
which i thought it was really remarkable
to see
um i'm assuming was that kind of just
how it was throughout
where you know she's sort of leading the
charge and
it's here but she's following her in
that i think
i think uh i think it's interesting in a
sense that
she's she's very like i think many
teenagers
are stubborn i think maybe that was one
of the things that i laughed about in
in in that back seat of the car in a
sense yeah that you know
i think anyone who has been a teenager
or have had
teenage children know that weird thing
where
you know teenagers you know they don't
want you to be there and you're just an
annoying parent
but at the same time in that age you
still kind of have fun with your parents
and you still need
lots of help from them with logistics
and i think that kind of that kind of
power balance is something which is very
interesting
and and which is portrayed but what to
the difference that greta i think is a
bit more stubborn than
than the average kind of teenager which
of course i've
i've noted filming her and also also why
i decided this kind of more verite style
because i didn't want to interfere with
her
activism and asking her to do stuff
because that was just you know
impossible instead i felt like okay but
i i
i more try to capture what goes on
in this kind of way instead
so i imagine it would be very exciting
and also challenging for you as a
filmmaker in
because as you're making the film the
story is blowing up like her reach and
her voice
is just becoming bigger and bigger and
more impactful and it's
amazing the the the scenes you got of
her meeting with macron or the eu
or um like she just goes from like i
mean you have a meeting with the pope
you you have
arnold schwarzenegger it's like everyone
wants to talk to her and you're there
filming throughout that entire process
um can you talk what sort of crew did
you have was it i'm imagining it was
very small i don't know if it was just
you or if there were other people but
how did you especially on the travel
segments how did you approach that from
the production perspective no but it's
in that sense it's so nice to to talk to
you guys which know the kind of hassles
but also the positives of
independent filmmaking in a sense uh
because in this
in this film i've been very uh lonely in
the sense that
we didn't have any funding in the
beginning anything
except from a small sum from the swedish
public broadcaster like the equivalent
of the bbc here in sweden
and uh so i decided to show this my
staff
as a dop i have a background in and as a
as a cinematographer and and also
quickly understood that
this is also the way to kind of get into
these rooms as you express
like things were happening very quickly
and on this kind of very high political
level
sometimes having a big crew actually
makes it harder to get in it's it's it's
even now ridiculously hard just to be
able to to to kind of sneak into those
rooms
and i i figured that if i if i kind of
present myself as
as this kind of just one person and an
independent filmmaker
it might be easier than if i run in with
two dops
two sound engineers and that really kind
of struck gold in the sense that
uh i was able to get into many places
where
other journalists and filmmakers
couldn't get
big because uh yeah they didn't have
time to kind of
to getting the access and also that they
didn't have the right kind of
quickness in their setup yeah
interesting um so one of the
key elements of greta denver's story and
that comes out in the film
is discussed quite a bit is the fact
that she has asperger's
and ocd and selective mutism
you know she and she talks about those
things when you first met her i'm
assuming you that you were not aware of
those things so that would have been
something you learned about her in the
process
was that um well i'm not sure what my
question is about that except just how
you as a filmmaker you
like that's a big element to introduce
into a story about climate activism and
um was was she was she and her father
pretty open about that up front or was
that something that you had to navigate
no very much open i think in the sense
that
i remember that she she had this
i think it was a twitter account already
from starting her activism
and on that account there was you know
15 year old climate activist with
asperger's syndrome
or something so she was very open with
with the diagnosis and i asked her a lot
about it
in the beginning and noted how she kind
of always came back to talking about it
because i
she's she's one of these people and i
maybe it's something swedish i
i don't know in a sense that i don't
think we in sweden see
asperger's necessarily as a disease as
some people
see it of course it's it comes with some
positives and it comes with some
negatives as
everything in life but here we we don't
have that kind of view of it
and i think she has really kind of encom
how to encompass that in her way of
speaking about it
and is so open so so it was more kind of
hard not to include it as it's
something that she kind of goes back to
over and over again it's something she
wants to kind of explain
so instead that became a part of why i
also kind of took this
direction of kind of get going more into
inside her kind of inner monologue
and lowering the camera camera down to
her kind of perspective
because instead of just kind of saying
those lines
kind of ocd and asperger's it's more of
you know what can i do as a filmmaker
okay i can try to understand what that
means and i can bring the camera down
to kind of that position and i think
that's where kind of cinematic
storytelling at least from from my point
of view
can make a difference in in comparison
to many other kind of literature and
and radio and and you know we we have
the ability
film to to um to get inside
uh people's kind of world um and and
with asperger
your world is is looking a little bit
differently and i think for greta it's a
very big part of why she became this
activist
and i think in the movie i at least
tried to to to show that
i mean one of the um striking things
about the film to me and
one of the most powerful visual elements
is just the amount of time that you
spend on her
on her and her face and she has a very i
mean through all these different
situations
you just you're always right there
capturing her as people around her
talking whether they're insulting her
or saying he's fawning over praising her
like whatever angle is coming from you
just
you're on her face and there's this
steady
calm uh she is expressive but there's a
certain uh
she's just taking it all in and you're
taking her intake
i mean it's i feel like i'm you really
get
a sense in this film of what it's like
to be her because you're just you're
seeing her reacting to everything
swirling around her and there's this and
the more the film goes on i feel like it
just builds this to me it might what i
took away from it was this sense of her
strength
and like she is not going to be shaken
in a way there's even a certain
repetition to it like she goes to all
these different events and she
she makes her speech she says what she's
going to say and there there's variation
there of course but
she's saying the same damn thing and
people just are not listening or they're
pretending to listen right that's i mean
it's the the adults
know what's going on but they take no
action
no but it's just calmly just
pointing it out over and over and over
yeah it's it's a very kind of special in
a sense
i remember talking to to my super
talented kind of
editing crew and you know we were
talking about okay but building
dramaturgy sometimes
you know you don't want to repeat things
but in this drama tragedy we have to
at least for one extent of the film
because that's
kind of what's so interesting with
climate change that the
issue right now when we're kind of in
this phase of i don't know climate
change
2.0 where we've at least understood what
it is but we're not acting
is that the issue is that we're
repeating this in news articles by
activists even politicians
but nothing is really happening so we
had to kind of pull that into
the the kind of dramatury of the movie
and also it's
it's uh it makes me very happy to hear
you kind of speak about that choice
because of course we've
we discussed a lot how can we kind of
how can we
how can we make a film that or i can
kind of how can i
interpret her world and i felt very
quickly that
i don't want to do this extravaganza
with flying drone
drones and and you know shooting her in
a dolly when she goes to
the you know school or whatever um
i just felt like let's like her world is
fairly simple and straightforward and
and and everything is kind of and she
she she's so focused on this thing she
sometimes doesn't hear you know
adults and we've even you know sometimes
when i shoot it's shot from a low angle
and we don't see
adults you know they're almost like
these kind of
uh these uh extras in a sense just kind
of walking outside of frame
and it's it's it's it's kind of it's not
a fancy
way of shooting but but it's uh i think
it's
as close to how she sees the world as i
could interpret it
as uh at least i wanted to ask about one
specific sequence in the film which is
her the boat trip across the atlantic to
go to the u.n
um i'm assuming you were on you were
clearly on the boat how long was that
trip and what was that experience
like i think it was a little bit more
than two
two weeks like 15 days ish um
the the sailing trip and of course i
don't want to spoil too much of the film
again but uh but it's uh
it was kind of i think many moments
during this kind of spectacular and
emotional year has been you know when
you have to pinch yourself in the arm
because it's like what is this like
things are going so quickly
but i would never have guessed that i
would say
over the atlantic in a carbon fiber
kind of racing boat on this story and i
remember when greta said that she had
posted on her
social media accounts that she was
looking for someone to take like to to
to take a ride over the atlantic
in a sailing boat uh but i didn't
understand then that the
guy who who said yes to this had this
you know was a racing sailor and did
this kind of
super harsh thing uh so
so it was came to a shock to me uh when
when
when uh when i spoke to him about this
and
and i was a bit reluctant actually in
the beginning to to to kind of join in
myself
uh because i i don't have that
experience of
kind of er of kind of extreme sports
filmmaking and so on
but i spoke to the captain and and he
said it was going to be bumpy
but not necessarily dangerous uh and
then i said you know okay but
i filmed this movie with this kind of
objective and this idea that i wanted to
tell
and this will definitely be a part of of
understanding
uh what struggle this is for her so uh
so i went on the boat and uh and
what can you say washing machine uh
maybe i don't know what kind of uh
that's what's so nice by being a
filmmaker in a sense
that you don't have to explain it kind
of in words because it's so many
years of shake water spray
um and sound uh so it
really looked it looked as you described
it looked
so safe but very challenging like you
got a sense of the speed
that you guys were going across that
water it was amazing
and also it just looked like such a
spare vessel that it must you must have
felt every
every time it hit the waves it must have
gone through you know i think that's
something
it's also so interesting because uh this
i'm so happy that the film
but it kind of took some time to kind of
make it in a sense that
that that people um i think people
even when these kind of activities
happened and when it was a lot in the
media
everything was covered so kind of
swiftly
and that's how the media media works
it's it's it's you know framing things
easily
and and i don't think people understood
that this you know
what what what this racing boat was you
know that it didn't look like this
like a v-shape like the these yachts
that you see in
marinas it was like flat like a
surfboard there's nothing in there
you know if when you go in you don't go
down there's there's nothing
it's just like flat because you don't
want to move
over the water as quick as possible so
so it was really
she she really decided to do something
very adventurous and uh as you can see
in the in the film of course that was
tough but
i also must admit that she actually
later on in the trip was
probably the one who kind of took it
best and me
which is you know i'm a grown up and one
of the captains we were actually the
ones that you know
lapping ourselves with these kind of
patches
with some kind of a nausea
thing so so um so it's interesting you
never know kind of who
takes these challenges uh kind of best
it's really one of
going out to the unknown uh doing this
um what kind of camera did you shoot the
the entire film on and on the boat were
you using the same rig
or did you have to kind of waterproof
things
yeah i'm gonna give you guys a very this
is the first time so this is you you're
getting exclusive tip here
which is uh so interesting because
before we were going to shoot on the
boat
um i talked to my producers and i was
like i don't know how to do this
and i i need i have found this guy and
he's like super expensive
but he's going to give me like a tech
list and they were like is it really
worth paying lots of money for just a
list
and like one call and i was like yeah
he's especially
he just filmed these weird notes and i
decided to push
through that and got that budget post
and every single thing that was set on
that
that kind of list with small kind of
bolts and
and batteries and and that we should we
had three you know we had three cameras
spare cameras uh
i think it was sony a7s like
the film the dslrs but we had so many
extras because he had this weird
kind of thing which like everything will
break and it did you know
in the end when we were sailing into the
us i think i only had one left
because one the audio didn't work and
the other one
needed a repair in the in the kind of
in the in some way so so it was you know
it was really
it was like the preparation for that
trip was so important
it looks kind of simple but but every
shot in there was
kind of what we really tried to prepare
yeah
wow um so the film
um another thing i want to say about the
film that struck me just in terms of
the story and the content and kind of
what you're the viewer is experiencing
is
like on the one hand it's this inspiring
story of this fierce
activist who's a remarkable person
on the other hand there's something very
depressing
right throughout she is there's no false
uh
optimism from her she is like repeatedly
saying
things are bad and we're reaching a
point where we can't turn it around
and people are hypocrites people say
they're going to do it and they don't
and there's just this
it never changes and and people are when
people praise her and say oh you're you
know
it's all about you she's like no it's
not about me like
she's so grounded and not
focused on herself and it's just
unrelenting like this sense of
we're racing towards you know
annihilation here
and she's pointing it out and nobody is
all these people whether it's the pope
or or macron or whomever
all these people wanting selfies with
her it's just so many of the adults seem
you know
on the one hand they appreciate her but
on the other hand they're just they're
totally missing it they're so frivolous
or they're just caught up in like
this kind of excitement without actually
doing what she's saying needs to be done
so i don't know i found it both
inspiring and also
enraging and depressing right what's
happening there
no but that's really interesting josh
and that's like that's a very
interesting kind of
balance i think once again it's
a little bit of a scandinavian kind of
trait uh in a sense uh i think
when you when you speak to more
international kind of
ways it's like is it inspirational or is
it investigative you know
and i think here in sweden we we
at least i yeah we have a tonality
sometimes where it could be you know but
it's truthful in the sense that
it is both inspirational and it also
carries this very
heavy load of kind of yeah so so and and
that does it becomes very bittersweet
in the sense that you know the sweetness
comes from from the strength of this
activism and the strength of
kind of seeing how greta is really doing
what she wants to do and how
how she's really using kind of uh
the the talent that she has and that
gives her something
but of course it's it's better in the
sense that you
see instantly how how she's you know
getting running into this brick wall of
of kind of a political establishment
and uh yeah and also worse than that
a wall of of of an adult world who to
some extent
uh really don't want to talk about this
because it's it's it's putting them into
a kind of bad situation
there is this generational you know
divide i think
which is kind of part of that of that
conflict
that that makes it a bit kind of uh
yeah hard to watch i think for some uh
because
you understand quickly that okay these
young people
they will kind of live their lives in
this future like when we're talking 20
50 20 60
those are not just numbers for them you
know those are important
quality life years when they are going
to you know get
their kids and live their lives and then
if you're a 50 60 or 70 year old
man mostly with the ones who will get
provocated by her
of course you won't live in that future
and
you want to have as much fun as you can
your last kind of 10
15 years and one of those things is
buying a new i don't know mustang or
whatever
right so you know it becomes that
conflict and
i think that's uh that's the large kind
of extent why people have been
attacking her they attack her as a
person because they don't want to speak
about those
facts and figures that she's presenting
because if they would speak about that
and research about those
then um much of their kind of ideas of
how they want to live their
life it would would kind of be hard
yeah um we've got uh
some questions here from the audience i
want to turn to uh the first one from
arthur
uh arthur writes fabulous film you had
amazing access beautiful intimate
moments
what's the possibility of doing a
feature film about her i'm assuming he
means fiction
i'm a fellow filmmaker and would love to
help so
is there talk of a narrative feature or
i don't know i don't know actually uh i
followed of course for a year and we
have contact in the sense that you know
not in the same way as when we were
filming but you know we text sometimes
if
there's something so so i don't know but
uh but
why not i of course sooner or later i i
bet someone will
uh will will kind of tell this this
story
on in the narrative space as well uh but
what i
think might be interesting now in a
sense is that
i think my film is is not like a biopic
i think it's more of like a prequel it
was actually
journalists who came up with that uh
kind of expression
uh so maybe we haven't really had this
kind of script yet for how credit is
going to evolve
um so i maybe it's it's a little bit
early i think to
to see where where yeah where this
activism is heading in a sense
another question comes from someone who
asks was greta's age a factor in what
access you had at all and was there
anything that her father did not want
included
yeah of course i think when it comes to
to anyone you're following and at least
from my perspective if it's
someone you know a homeless person or or
an activist or even
someone within the political
establishment you need to have an
like an ethical discussion about what
you're doing and i was very frank
towards
grad and her father you know that i need
to to do my point of view of this story
and you cannot
influence that um even though you know
she's a minor i need to do an interview
if it's
to be even you know possible to make a
film
but what i can say to you guys is that
in the end of the film you can come in
in the editing process and you can look
at
what i have kind of perceived as as this
story and you
and if there's anything then that you
don't think
it's kind of that you don't recognize
yourself and
we can have a discussion about that so i
brought her in uh in the end there uh
and of course the the father was also
with her and and and they watched the
movie and the only thing she said was
actually that she recognized herself and
she was you know
positive that this was showing her in
in in a much more nuanced way than this
very simplified stoic
and screaming angry girl and what she
didn't
want to do was remove but she wanted to
add so she was like can we more add more
context to that
can we add more here can you know she
wanted to make it longer
and we added some context to one scene
but of course i
explained to her you know that yeah
that's the problem of moviemaking that
we only have a particular space you know
we
can't do uh it made much longer than
that yeah
um another question uh were you able to
enjoy the film with an audience
yes uh luckily we were actually
finishing this film in a part of the of
the kind of culvert pandemic which was a
bit kind of slower
so it's been hitting cinemas in large
parts of europe
and it's been we we had we were
premiering at
venice film festival which was amazing
that we got into there
which is like the only festival that was
actually open this year
so it's screened for for a fairly large
audience and the biggest cinema they had
on the premiering day and it was you
know so special to be able to sit in a
in a cinema like that and see it
together with with an audience and i'm
i'm so happy that we we were you know of
course i was just lucky that
yeah that was you know the dip uh in
time so we were able to do that
um so so of course that was uh was uh
something which was great for me that's
that's wonderful
um this is sort of a big question but
i'm curious
obviously when a filmmaker makes a film
and releases into the world you hope for
lots of you you hope for an audience for
people to see it but i'm just curious
with this film in particular given that
it's about an activist
and you you're telling it from her point
of view what
what are your hopes for this film like
what do you want this film to do
no but i think i as a filmmaker i
i think it's very very important when we
when we kind of speak about public
figures
that we start to understand that they
are not one-dimensional
like they they are so much much more
than what we kind of
understand and i think to a large part i
wanted people to
to kind of really understand the full
kind of three-dimensionality of greta
that she's this you know she's she is
this angry girl but she's also a
teenager
and and she has this diagnosis but this
is more how the diagnosis feels
so i think it's this is not a story in
that sense about climate change it's
it's of course a story about her
um and and why i wanted to tell that was
because
i felt that that that was kind of
the missing piece that i felt in the
this
the narrative of of her and about
climate change at this moment that we
were talking
we were you know so much talking heads
and analysis around her
on one part and then it was you know so
much
figures and and numbers when it came to
climate change
and i was like somewhere in the between
there this this this
emotional story of her where she kind of
how she feels about this issue as a
young person
so i think uh i think many people will
understand her
and the young kind of point of view on
this issue better
and thus as we spoke about this
generational divide
maybe can actually you know if it's that
wide now maybe if you watch the movie
you can
get a little bit tighter as you know
young people can
say to her parents when they watch it
together like oh but this is how she
feels because she's worried about that
and then
you know it opens up for for discussion
and families that i i know has been very
uh
at least here in sweden it's been a big
thing and lots of people have watched it
kind of within the family and it sparked
lots of those discussions
it's interesting as you were saying that
i flashed back to the beginning of the
film where
she has that encounter on the street on
the street outside the parliament
with the older woman who's like yeah
really be in school and that's how you
can change the world
and i love that exchange like you could
tell the woman was not happy with greta
but
they were talking to each other and it
was like a
it was a conversation from these very
different generations it was just it was
a beautiful moment
um yeah i think it's so interesting and
it kind of starts with that that scene
uh uh which kind of sets the kind of
yeah agenda for for the kind of the the
young
first the old in a stance and then and
i think there's an american activist and
this kind of more montage when we can
open up the world
who says like where are parents where
are grandparents and i think it's this
it's not like it's not in in any way the
main kind of threat of the dramaturgy
but it's definitely
a very important sub story that i think
i've at least seen many people and
families that i've seen and that's what
kind of
goes back into their discussions kind of
and many parents and grandparents who
become kind of uh
maybe at first they feel a little bit
bad
for kind of not having being able to to
take the responsibility but it also
opens
up for i think people kind of yeah yeah
because i like narrowing that gap in a
sense because having that conflict is
not going to be beneficial for anyone
you know i wanted to in closing i wanted
to mention something this is a little
bit off topic but
um recently i did a
another q a with two filmmakers from
ireland the co-directors of a great
animated feature that's about to come
out called wolf
walkers they're the filmmakers who did
secret of
and um or book of kell in the song
beautiful irish animation and their new
film wolf walkers which is coming out
later this month on apple plus
is uh it's about a young girl in ireland
um
during the time i think it's 17th
century when the british have come over
and they're
like killing all the wolves and burning
down forests and there's a big scene of
a
forest being annihilated as part of
getting rid of the wolves
and this girl it's kind of a super
somewhat supernatural story she becomes
friends with another girl who
might be able to turn into a wolf and
communes with the wolves
so it's about it's this relationship
between two two young girls
in the woods of ireland and um as i was
watching your
film i that you have that scene and i
don't know if it's in sweden or what
country it's in but um
where greta is brought with some other
people and they're looking at this
expanse
where the forest used to be and you can
see way off the trees in the distance
and there's a shot of greta
like walking up to the tree line and
i mentioned that to the filmmakers of
this irish film i said you know i just
saw this
great documentary greta dunberg and they
said she was an inspiration to them
in making wolf walkers they were
thinking of her
specifically of like this fierce young
girl who's you know facing environmental
degradation and standing up to it you
know in
very different films totally different
but if you get to see wolf walker it's
it's
i think you might recognize gravity or
interesting and in a sense
i understand i think it's it's like it
shares
of course like connections to to many
other
kind of stories in a sense of you know
david versus goliath and and you know
that kind of uh uh a narrative that
which
is someone who's small that goes up
against something which is
actually you know impossible to fight do
you think and so on
so it seems interesting i i would love
to watch it
um it's a couple more questions here uh
i'm going to jump to the end there's one
here
i am a middle school student and i was
wondering what things people of my age
can do to help fight against climate
change
hi so nice to to hear that you're
watching this
q a as well um no but there's lots of
things that you can do
and i and i think the first thing that
you can do is of course
to talk to your parents and your friends
about this
and to to hear what kind of what they
think
and and read up on some kind of climate
science and start discussing that with
them
there's lots of great websites on the
internet that kind of is connected to
the united nations which is a very kind
of
stable and truthful source that kind of
encompasses
uh kind of the more kind of true
scientific view of what's happening so
that's
really good to look out for uh so i
think that's that's the good starting
point
uh and then there's of course things you
can do
privately as a private person you can
you know try to eat less meat or you can
try to avoid flying and so on going by
train if it's possible
so those are kind of small things that
you can do as a as a private citizen but
you should also remember that that we as
as kind of
private persons we can do one thing but
there's also kind of what we call
systemic things which is more
kind of on a society basis and there you
may be not
have the right to vote for instance but
then you can yeah you can strike for
instance from school you can find your
local school strike movement that could
be one way of turning your voice
up as you're a minor and and cannot uh
and cannot vote so there's lots of
things you can do but we read up on it
and
and do something that's always the best
thing to do something
great question and answer um another
question from gail gilbert asks could
you please talk about working with your
story editor and when did you begin that
in the process
great question i love hearing people
mentioning those fantastic people we we
need them as documentary filmmakers
and in this process it was more kind of
a step-by-step thing
as we kind of went into an early editing
and
and compiled like rough rough cut which
was very long
and then one story editor came in and we
were together and she was really good
and she
actually jumped into the editing bay and
then as she you know touches
that's something which is really good to
know all filmmakers out there
as soon as your story editor becomes
your editor find another story editor
because you know as you touch the the
kind of keyboard and start editing
you lose that perspective so then we
found another
story editor whose name is per who's a
danish
very you know he's one of the top uh
editors and of documentaries globally
and he loved the story and loved the
material and uh
and then denmark and sweden we speak the
same language so
we worked together in the last
kind of three months i think two and a
half months of editing
and he was he was like there on a weekly
basis
looking at rough cuts and everything
great
and then one more question um could you
actually this is also from gail
uh could you please speak about um
greta's mother and the fact that she was
only present in the home movies
and then the emotional scene near the
end
yeah it's of course the movie is kind of
a
verite thing which kind of just follows
her and
as this year progressed it turned into a
road movie uh so actually
where i had most access but also what
was kind of making sense in
in kind of the storytelling was this
kind of constant
on the road and as i uh i don't
remember if i said it in this q a or
something else but
as the father is what we call a hammer
papa which is like
at home he was the one
going with her and became kind of the
family member to bounce it but and then
when we were back in sweden in some
scenes we could kind of bring her in but
that was very
little uh of of kind of the story
well nathan i want to thank you so much
for for
coming and doing this q a today it's
been great talking with you and
i'm a huge admirer of the film and at
film independent we will uh
do what we can to help spread the word
and and really share
share your work with an audience here